This app was built using the animate
camera method that you saw in
the previous video.
Note that it has three buttons,
just like in a previous
application that you built, and
each of these buttons animates map
movement to a different location.
So, for example, I'm now looking
at a map of the United States, but
if I tap on Seattle you see
the camera is going to animate.
As I zoom into Seattle,
taking a few seconds to do so.
It's a really cool effect.
So once I'm in on Seattle, there you
can see some of Seattle, including,
you can even see here an indoor map of
the Pacific Science Center in Seattle.
I can for example then touch on Tokyo.
And you'll see I'll fly up and
out into orbit, and
then back down over the Pacific
until I land on Tokyo, like so.
And again,
you can see I'm now in downtown Tokyo.
And if I so desire,
I can also go to Dublin.
Now here there's a case of I haven't
pre-cached some of these tiles, so
you're just seeing blank
as it's flying over.
And it'll soon land on Dublin.
So if I zoom out of Dublin, you can
see those tiles are getting cached.
So none of these tiles were
pre-cached for testing the video,
and that's why we couldn't see
when we flew from Tokyo to Dublin.
If I just zoom out and
effectively cache the tiles,
I'm not doing anything
myself to cache them.
This is just how
the application is running.
And so the map fragment itself
will cache the tiles for you.
So here you can see Japan, and
if I go back somewhere over Ireland and
now I tap on Tokyo, you'll see
that the orbit will change, and
I'll drop down onto Tokyo.
And now if I try to go to Dublin,
you'll see I fly out of Japan,
up over the surface of the Earth,
over Asia, over China,
back over western Europe before
dropping down and onto Dublin.
So you know have everything you need
to build this application yourself.
You've all the tools.
Why don't you give it a shot?
If you have any trouble, the source
code is linked to the speaker nodes.